now Lebanon is bracing for more anger on
the streets as the economy sinks further
due to the corona virus outbreak armed
soldiers and military vehicles are on
patrol in Tripoli that's after a night
of demonstrations against the
government's handling of the economy
turned violent a 26 year old man was
killed in clashes with security forces
in Tripoli and in Beirut people defied a
coronavirus lockdown throwing petrol
bombs and vandalizing banks Zana Hodder
is in Tripoli for us in northern Lebanon
joins us from there so I can see behind
you looks like some smoke looks like
some people on the streets of things
heating up again
yes Samy things are heating up again
chaos in the streets of this northern a
city anti-government protesters trying
to block roads they've been vandalizing
banks it's what they did really last
night as protesters at protests turned
into riots the Lebanese army out in
force they are responding with tear gas
and this is why we have to move away and
at the same time some of these
protesters are quite violent because
they don't want us to film their faces
as they vandalize public and private
property so the situation is quite tense
people here are saying they have nothing
to lose economic hardships that they're
facing it has been worsening in recent
days as you can hear rubber-coated
bullets are being used by the Lebanese
army in recent days the Lebanese lira
lost lost its value it depreciated at
least 60% so people here the majority of
people here earn their salaries in
Lebanese liras so they've they've lost
the value of their money and many others
here are unemployed tens of thousands of
people have lost their jobs in recent
months this economic crisis is not new
it was made worse by the lockdown the
containment measures to cut to battle
the corona virus but this problem this
crisis has been going on for months now
movement began in October that protest
movement now revived as the situation
the economic and financial situation
worsens by the day Zana alright if you
need to take cover I'm not sure if if
you can still talk so you know feel free
to tell me if you need to yeah but what
I was going to say is you know a lot of
the reporting talks about the lockdown
making things even worse economically
for people there the pictures we're
looking at now doesn't look like a whole
lot of lockdown there's a lot of people
out on bikes in cars standing around
burning things there the lockdown has
been eased to a certain extent the
government realized is that at the end
of the day people have to return to work
a lot of these people rely on daily
wages to survive and according to the
authorities in many ways they've been
able to contain the virus some 700 cases
24 deaths on a daily basis approximately
ten new infections but at the end of the
day there's not a lot of testing being
done but you talk to anybody here and
they say coronavirus well we're dying
from hunger our children are asking us
for food our children are hungry and we
cannot afford to buy food inflation more
than 50% an increase of more than 50%
and that is according to the economy
minister so officials are acknowledging
this crisis but they haven't come up
with any plan to solve this crisis
Lebanon needs cash it needs hard
currency there's a shortage of dollars
and it doesn't have many friends in the
international community so the
government really has little options to
solve this problem and in the interim
you're seeing people becoming more and
more a poorer and finding it really
difficult to survive as you're talking
they're saying that the the black smoke
is really billowing now what exactly is
on I assume something's on fire down
there right can you tell us what exactly
are we looking at down at the end of
that street the banks the banks so
that's a bank on fire obviously people
right then they're not happy I guess
with the fact that they can't get enough
money out no capital controls informal
capital controls have been in place
since November so you have really no
access to your savings this is but many
of these people here do not have bank
accounts these are the impoverished
people of Lebanon who cannot find at
work who if they don't work today then
they can't feed their children
but yes banks have imposed controls the
Banking Association says they have no
other choice because they don't want
capital flight and that there's a
liquidity crisis in the country and that
they lent the money to the state and the
politicians wasted public funds and the
states defaulted on its debt and
couldn't pay banks back so many people
blame the banks and even if you have a
dollar account of this minimum flow you
can see the army deploy in force
they are deploying yeah so if you have a
dollar account the the banks are
dispersing your money in Lebanese lira
which has lost value so there is an
undeclared haircut but it's not just the
banking sector people are upset our
people are accepted the political elite
which they blame really for years of
mismanagement years of corruption and
now the state is closed for bankruptcy
and like I said Lebanon needs cash the
international community will not provide
money they've made this very very clear
unless politicians implement what's
needed structural and economic reforms
and politicians are reluctant to do that
why because if they do that then they
lose access to the state's resources
which many accuse them of using
exploiting for political gain so there
is a real crisis the state is under
pressure the new government says well
we're all technocrats we were we were
you know we took office in January we're
not responsible for this crisis but
their opponents will say well those who
appointed you our political parties who
have been governing for
decades and now what you have is
political tensions worsening between the
government and the opposition
Zana just to take him what's happening
because this looks a little surreal I
guess to viewers perhaps from around the
world on the left side of the screen
down there we've got a bank on fire on
the right side of the screen we can see
soldiers just over your shoulder milling
around and everyone just seems to be a
little bit relaxed about all of this I
mean what kind of of measures are they
trying are they trying to take back
control of the situation or they just
resigned to what seems to be a country
and not just an economy almost in
freefall at this point
[Music]
well Lebanon really is a country which
is immune to violence years and years of
conflicts political instability so for
many Lebanese what is going on here
today is not unusual but there is no
doubt this is a very dangerous situation
the country is at a crossroads
people are growing hungry the state is
trying to impose its authority on the
ground the army will say that we allow
you to peacefully protest you can gather
but we will not allow people to destroy
public and private property we will take
action and it seems this is what the
Lebanese army is trying to do now take
control of the street try to restore
calm
they are deploying on main roads as we
notice a lot of the protesters have now
left on their motorcycles people are
worried of you know being arrested last
night there have there were a number of
arrests at the same time there were
injuries not just among the protesters
you mentioned earlier one protester was
killed but there were injuries among the
army soldiers as well and the army
releasing a statement not too long ago
saying that they will investigate the
shooting incident that resulted in the
death of the protester because this is
this wasn't the intense
to launch an investigation will it calm
the street it's hard to say because
we've been talking to people here and
what they tell you is that the army
shouldn't be shooting at us the army
should be taken action taking action
against politicians who they call
corrupt politicians they say that these
politicians should be taken to prison
instead of you know the states using
their weapons against the Lebanese
people so it is what we were seeing now
really is a warning or a sign of what's
to come if there is no solution to the
worst economic crisis this country is
facing in decades the lira is still at
an official rate of one thousand five
hundred and if you withdraw money from
the bank that's how much they give you
again stay dollar but but there are no
dollars in banks so you exchange it in
the street it's now four thousand lira
so you can imagine what it means for
people who earn in the Lebanese pound
and with inflation skyrocketing more
than 50 percent I'm sorry I see what we
can hear you down the shots I think that
was gunshots there just tell us what's
going on and of course needless to say
take cover if you need to know this it
seems like the the army is using
rubber-coated bullets in order to as
well as tear gas to disperse protesters
they're trying to clear this square the
square is really symbolic because when
the protest movement began in October
this was where people were gathering
this was the main protest site so the
army is trying to clear the square
close the roads link that that lead to
the Bank Street you can see the army we
can't ask them any questions the army
will not speak to us but it is clear
what they're trying to do they're trying
to take control if you can see the tear
gas they're lobbing tear gas we can see
the white smoke I'm assuming that's
that's tear gas right that but it's not
clear you know that looks like the
protesters have cleared off now at this
point I'm not sure who they're shooting
tear gas hatch
well they they wanna clear clear the
square you can see some some young men
still on their motorcycles the biggest
question is what will happen in a few
hours time the people we just returned
to the streets is this going to stop
them yes they were truly the very fact
that they all dispersed and ran away a
lot of them are afraid of being arrested
so hang on a minute saying that so just
to clarify then the guys that we're
seeing on motorbikes are they the
protesters has this protest movement
transformed into sort of mobile
motorbike protest movement no but a lot
of lot of people from Tripoli use
motorbikes because it is a very
impoverished City people cannot afford
cars and that's why so no what we saw
throughout the day and last night where
people in the streets demonstrate being
gathering in the square as well as
targeting and vandalizing Thanks so this
is you can clear the square now but the
biggest question like I said what
happens and then in the next few hours
if the economic crisis is not resolved
of cabinet the Lebanese government was
in session a short while ago they just
finished their meeting we didn't hear
any anything about an economic rescue
plan this is what the government calls
it a rescue plan on how to deal with the
crisis
nothing's presented so far they did
suggest touching people's deposits and
banks to try to really fund the state
but there was an uproar and people went
against that so what is the government
going to do it is close to bankruptcy
and people are only getting angrier and
the tens of thousands have lost their
jobs in the past in the past few months
hundreds of restaurants have closed
hotel occupancy down to 10% and that was
even before the coronavirus lockdown the
tourism sector has been hit hard many
sectors have been hit hard by this
crisis so it is really Lebanon has been
at the crossroads many many many times
in the past it has reached turning
points many many times in the past since
the end of the civil war in 1990 but
never before has the situation been this
bad where like I said a state close to
bankruptcy and very little friends in
the international community nobody seems
interested in just bailing Lebanon out
unless there are reforms and those in
power are clinging on to that power so
semi it is quite a precarious situation
Zana on that point that you mentioned
about the cabinet was meeting today one
of the things which was reported that
they would be looking at is a potential
what's called a haircut of up to 70% on
bondholders do we have any idea if
they've gone for those kinds of measures
no the Prime Minister realized how much
opposition he faced when that was leaked
to the media
a few weeks back the Prime Minister even
have to make a televised address and
make clear that if there's any haircut
on bank deposits it would only affect 2
percent of bank deposits that means milk
those who have millions of dollars and
they're believed to be the politicians
the big businessmen who are you know
friends with with the politicians and
that's why you saw every politician and
suddenly suddenly raise their voice and
say no we are not going to accept this
and the people of course say and some of
the politicians even said that we're not
going to pay the price for the
government the way that they've
mismanaged the economy all these years
so that doesn't seem to be on the table
any longer at least at least not 90% of
the deposits in the banks but semi a
haircut has already happened because
when you're not allowed to withdraw your
dollar deposits in dollars and you would
draw it in Lebanese liras at the
official rate of one thousand five
hundred then that is a 60 percent
haircut on your deposits and a lot of
Lebanese work abroad they send their
money back home and and the banks were
really providing people with high
interest rates trying to lure hard
currency and in the country and that is
why the central bank governor has been
criticized for his monetary policies it
is a very complicated situation the
government says it's going to fight
corruption the government says it's
going to enact laws to take politicians
to court but the biggest question is can
it do that yes maybe Hassan jab is he
calls himself an independent and all his
ministers are independent just let me
jump in they were looking at pictures if
the camera man pans back to the right
there something's on fire I assume what
is I an ATM machine yes this is a cash
machine yes this is a cash machine
they've been vandalizing cash machines
the facade of banks since last night in
Tripoli but in the past
a few days brank bank branches and other
cities in Lebanon have been vandalized
and we've seen this happen before at the
beginning of them when the protest
movement began in October a lot of the
banks were vandalized because of those
capital controls because of the fact
that people couldn't access their
savings so how significant is this is it
this is a 'no to see images like this in
a place like tripoli i mean
lebanon is no stranger to violence but
for so much of its recent history that
violence has been so attached to
factions ethnic religious divides we saw
tripoli at the beginning of the syrian
revolution get wrapped up in some of
that but this is different right now
correct well to a certain extent yes it
is about poverty people from all sects
coming together and demanding a change
of leadership that's what we saw in
October but at the same time there was
at least half of the population still
supporting the mainly sectarian
political parties this definitely the
what people here call their uprising
their revolution did not have the
support of the majority of the Lebanese
people many Lebanese still supported
their parties for a number of reasons
they were benefiting from them they gave
them jobs or for ideological reasons for
that matter and that is one of the
reasons why and the protest movement was
not really able to achieve much and then
there is of course the fact that the
state fought back they clung on to power
those in power have been in power for
decades they know how to hold on to
power they control the army they control
the internal security forces so the
people were up against the military
state and there was a lot of arrests and
violence we've seen scenes like this
back in December and in January so a lot
of people were really discouraged from
returning to the streets they felt that
even if we returned to the streets it's
not going to achieve much it's not going
to change the leadership there must be
other ways
to do to do that and a lot of people
have been calling for early elections
the the politicians are are not heating
that call either but you say Tripoli and
you say sectarian politics well that's
where it is quite dangerous because this
is a city a majority Sunday City which
feels that they no have no say in the
government the Sunnis according to
Lebanon's power-sharing sectarian system
they should hold the post of Prime
Minister yes Hassan diem is the 'sydney
but he was not appointed by the Sunni
community he doesn't have the support of
the Sunni community so they feel other
sects have taken over their
constitutional powers so that's another
layer to the to the conflict in Lebanon
but as you can see the army is now out
in force they're blocking roads leading
to the Bank Street they are now in
control of this of this area Tripoli but
the biggest question we have to see is
whether or not they'll be able to
maintain control in the next hours or
days to come alright good stuff there
from xenical they're updating us on a
very dynamic and fluid situation in the
northern Lebanese city of Tripoli as
we've been saying Lebanon's economy has
been in freefall for months with jobs in
short supply and the government
struggling under massive debts over the
past week the currency has fallen
rapidly forcing the central bank to set
the selling price of dollars at 3,200
pounds for money transfer firms the
government is in talks with the
International Monetary Fund for a
bailout the five-year plan aims to boost
growth to 2% by 2024 it requires 10 to
15 billion dollars though while the
money is much needed with the IMF
forecasting Lebanon's economy shrinking
by 12 percent this year Walid Fardeen is
a media scholar and activist in Beirut
he says people have nothing left to lose
in Lebanon what the people are worried
about now is not only the lockdown
it's the collapsing economy and the
continuous failure of the alleged
government of Sandia which actually did
not got ever get a vote of confidence
it's got a minority vote in the
Parliament less than half the Parliament
voted for it however due to the support
of Hezbollah to this governor it was
formed they promised that they will come
up with economical solutions they will
get some kind of support and economical
help to Lebanon they fail not much have
been done till today there is no plan of
going out of this financial crisis the
people have no other choice but to go
out to the states again to demonstrate
definitely there gonna be riots there
gonna be kind of violence to the fact
that people just lost over 60% of the
income or of the value with a
devaluation of the Lebanese pound
other than that many companies are
shutting down when they were coronavirus
people who are locked down so other
companies aren't paying salaries with
all of this this little that has been
done by our government